hello thanks for calling Mario's Pizza  this is Carlos speaking  we would like a large pie with pepperoni  pineapple and cheesy crust large  pepperoni with pineapple and cheesy  crusts we would also like a large pie  with bacon pineapple  and cheesy broth large bacon pineapple  with cheesy crust okay is that going to  complete your order sir you know what  let me use the room uh guys are we gonna  want another Pizza let me just who's  hungry show her hands let me see them  one two three keep them up four five six  yep pretty big one too come on guys keep  them up Hugo summer hands food you know  what let's play it safe let's get  another pie